would you get 50 of your income each
year to charity well mccaskill is one of
the founders of the effective altruism
movement who does exactly that and
apparently it's 10xed his personal
happiness money does by happiness my
best guess is that just at least until
you're at a very high level that
actually keeps going up every doubling
of your income results in the same
increase in happiness so you go from one
thousand dollars a year to two thousand
that's the same as going from a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousand yeah in
terms of your increase in happiness
giving is a good is like enjoyable
itself yeah so if I think about what's
been the impact on my well-being from
donating most of my income well I have a
much more meaningful life and now part
of this like wide community of people
who I just love and admire and source of
joy in my life it means that like when
I'm feeling down and like not liking
myself very much and like well at least
I'm doing something like you know I'm
really helping other people and there's
just this literature as well on
volunteering on giving gives this kind
of warm glow and sometimes people give
only for the warm glow but you get it
even if you're aiming just to help
others as much as you can